and all of them actually do this
interesting thing i'd love to hear your
opinion on it
asander certainly does it to a large
degree which is
it's in the process of delegation
trusting a person to do a really
difficult thing
like tossing it up
uh saying like i trust
you can get this job done
for some even if your resume does not
support that
i'm actually kind of uh amazed the human
beings when they're given the trust
to get the job done they step up very
often that's kind of an amazing property
of human nature
people often ask me issues about
leadership and i always say that one of
the best
tools for teaching leadership and for
teaching a bunch of other lessons
is leadership itself yeah so when it
happens all the time when you elevate
someone into a leadership position
they do step up and they do make things
happen
so that's not surprising to me you do
have to
mitigate risk so saying hey you know lex
i know you're
haven't been in the military before i
know you have
very limited weapons experience but i
want you to run
a target assault on a real mission in
whatever country
that would not be good that would not be
a good move on on my part
now if i said all right lex you know
what i want you to get some leadership
experience
i've got a training mission and it's
going to be using paintball
and i'm going to put you in charge of it
i got no problem doing that
some of that is judging human character
it's like there's potential there's
something in this person
that they are they have enough demons or
whatever the hell it requires to have
that fuel
they'll figure it out they'll hate
themselves if they don't
and they'll find the right they'll find
the tools to find the path they'll
to to achieve the whatever the level of
perfection they can it's been really
surprising to me it's been
making me rethink of the whole hiring
process
because i often now i'm thinking looking
so i'm looking for people both for the
startup but just for my own life
for help and i almost want to see
evidence of excellence but maybe
you want to just based on just judgment
of human character
without evidence of excellence have
people step up
you